and this goes back to last week I was
talking about how I believe that a lot
of children have anxiety if they were
breastfed on a cup breasts because
trying to get that milk out of that
little that little you know a little
leche rattler
I mean that's you imagine how
frustrating that is for a child let's
hear more because I'm one of them I just
want to say I don't think it's related
to anxiety because it actually has very
little to do with breast size your milk
production so uh okay we'll use let's
hear more so you have to blame your
anxiety on someone other than your most
food thank you I love the show have a
good one
well thank you for calling and I love
you I love you actually you sound like a
really nice person but I'm gonna say
this so you're saying from your side of
the bar that's your side of the bar that
there's no heed that the size of that
taught doesn't affect that milk
production well let me tell you what
it's like from the other side you know
from my side of the bar when you belly
up to that small breasts man you just
it's like going to work when you get
that big regular breasts you know you
see your buddy over there and he got
that big walrus in his mouth and you
over there just [__] trying to milk a
cricket off your mama's little lake cut
that thing it does create a lot of
hecticness and it's hard to get that
rattle out of your out of you for the
rest of your life you'll never forget
how much you got a rattle that milk out
of a small breast but I respect you
saying you know the other side of it and
look there's two views to every window
you know ohm word let's hear another
call hi I'm Lea my name I'll coach you
comment oh she's leaving her name how
boy so this is that dark Avenger right
here just Bruce Wayne up in here thank
you for calling young lady
let's hear more about the young anxiety
that you said about the small boobs or
whatever and also about conception doggy
style oh yeah yeah I also believe that a
lot of children that are misbehaviors or
could possibly be conceived doggy style
or the
how a child is conceived could them
determine how it behaves in life or how
a person behaves because I've definitely
seen some of them
MDS bees baby them doggystyle babies and
they uh they're often up to no good
so missionary conception if you want
more of a passive child I believe but
also with the [__] do I know bruh but
thank you for calling in young lady
let's hear it I actually have some
anecdotal verification of that one of my
children was conceived on about the most
anxious child you have ever met okay so
Exhibit A right there this lady's got
that DSB you know share that doggystyle
baby right there and I can that's Wow
it's wild to hear a woman that is a
brave enough to admit it and I commend
you you know you just straight-up Amelia
Earhart of being on your knees right now
you're you're brave enough to admit that
you conceive a child doggystyle and I
respect that and I respect you young
lady let's hear more my other one was
not and he is chill as hell there there
are two years in two days apart there's
this same it's just weird
when you said that I lost it Wow proof
baby this is proof right here a son you
know what I'm saying
call me Arthur Conan Doyle bruh thank
you guys for checking out this clip and
if you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz it's alarming